[Music]
edith is with us in denver colorado hi
edith welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave i'm so happy to be able to talk
with you you too what's up
um um my husband and i have been
together
for about six years and uh we had a
child about
19 months ago and
i believe in in colorado they
acknowledge
common-law marriage despite us
being married only two months officially
married two months ago
um after this time that he and i have
been together
he's asking me for a post nuptial
because he says he wants to protect his
assets from before our marriage um
saying that he is
14 years older than me at 48 years old
and me 34.
he wants to protect his assets because
he's closer to retirement
um and i wanted to see what what you
think about that
considering he and i have been
technically only married to
two marines but i don't know it's
common-law marriage matters
and also that um you know
him well what he's what he's asking for
that yeah
so you're married for two months you
have a baby you used to live with him
for years before that
and now he comes up and says um
he wants a post nup because if y'all get
divorced he wants to be able to keep all
his stuff
right does that not hurt you does that
not hurt your feelings and scare you
it does scare me i'm sorry it scares me
it
hurts me yeah um
if you were my little sister i'm a
redneck hillbilly i'd be tempted to
punch him in the nose
that's how it makes me feel when i hear
it
what an irresponsible selfish twit who
has a brand new wife and a brand new
baby and all he can think about is
protecting his own butt
that's what that's what's coming through
my mind now i just said it all out loud
i did i said all that out loud didn't i
yeah so there you go you know
i mean we have a manhood crisis in this
culture
good lord what a little child
so that's how i feel now what do you do
about it is another thing
um i i think there's a lot going on here
and um if i were in your shoes
for the good of your child and the good
of your future marriage i think you've
got to dig
out all the toxicity and poison and get
it cleaned out for you to have a good
clean relationship going forward
and that's called marriage counseling so
the answer is no i would not give him a
postnup
um but the fact that he asks for it
indicates there are issues that need to
be dealt with would you agree with that
uh yes we we have issues
mostly stemming
he and i have been having fights over
the same thing
for four years because for the past two
years has he has been
working and living in oklahoma while
i stay and work and take care of our
daughter in colorado
why he comes to see us because he's he's
there
because he's uh he wants to make the
money that makes a really good money
well why don't you move to oklahoma with
your husband
i i very much enjoy my my life in in
colorado yeah but you married a guy who
moved to oklahoma
yes y'all are weird
yes it's it's
he's moved to several different states
in pursuit of this of this
various jobs and i want to be able to
settle down and i want him to come
to colorado and be with me and the baby
here
i wish i wish i could i wish i could
roll back time and tell you not to have
a child or marry this guy
i wish i could but we're not there now
so you guys have got to work on some of
these issues
and you got to decide if you're going to
move with your man or not and
and if he's gonna be your man or not or
if he's gonna continue to be a freaking
little boy
um this is this is you all got all kinds
of stuff going on here
and you really do not have any
probability
of staying together like zero you're
going to be divorced
if you don't deal with this stuff you
have you've given me two
really major red flags i'm not a family
therapist
i've just worked with people who divorce
all the time for 30 years
and i can just see this coming just like
a just like an old man that has seen
stuff coming so that's
that's me old ugly uncle dave your car
is running right towards the wall and
everybody has his foot their foot all
the way down on the accelerator it's
going to completely implode when it hits
the wall
if you guys don't deal with this stuff
and
this this post nup thing is a symptom
and this
moving around thing is a symptom and
there's a problem under there
that you all got to dig up and deal with
that's my voice advice to you little
sister
and if he was my little sister for real
that's exactly what i would tell you
you need to be in the pastor's office
you need to be in the counselor's office
and just be sitting and getting some
good pre-marriage counseling it's the
only way you got a chance
if you do not address these issues you
will not
be married much longer because he's
going to be in another state he's going
to find him another woman
that's what's going to happen if he
hadn't already that's what's coming